who should police social media twitter
reports it's received a record number of
government requests to remove content so
is this a way to maintain a safe and
open internet for all or is it
censorship this isn't that's true
hello and welcome to the program i'm
imran khan most social media firms have
made the same promise to provide a free
and open platform for users to express
themselves but they're coming under
increasing pressure to remove content
deemed offensive or illegal twitter says
it's received a record number of
government requests to remove tweets in
the first six months of last year just
five countries made 95
of the demands japan russia turkey india
and south korea in 54 of cases twitter
withheld content or ask users to remove
posts but the firm says the request
revealed a deeply worrying trend against
freedom of expression
the social media giant has had a rocky
relationship with some governments
twitter imposed restrictions and warning
labels ahead of the u.s election in 2020
users received a prompt pointing them to
credible information before they could
retweet content labeled as misleading
following the capitol hill riots last
year twitter permanently banned former
u.s president donald trump after he
expressed support for the rioters
and in february 2021 india demanded the
removal of content saying it was
promoting violence at the height of the
farmer's protests against agricultural
reform laws
twitter also deleted hundreds of tweets
but refused to deactivate the accounts
of media outlets the indian government
responded by threatening twitter
employees with up to seven years in jail
last june nigeria suspended the social
media firm after it deleted a tweet by
president muhammadu buhari in which he
promised to punish local groups he
blamed for violence twitter said that
violated its policy on abusive behavior
and two weeks ago twitter agreed to
register in nigeria and pay local taxes
to end a seven month ban
let's bring in our guest in london quinn
mchugh executive director of article 19
a human rights organization defending
freedom of expression and information in
maastricht viglenza abazi assistant
professor of european law at maastricht
university and a fellow at yale law
school and also in london melody patri
advocacy director access now a
non-profit organization defending the
digital rights of users around the world
welcome all to the program let's begin
in london with quinn
mchugh twitter says this is a deeply
worrying trend against freedom of
expression but the governments are
saying they're just clamping down on
illegal activity who's right
uh
thank you very much for having me today
i think
the truth lies more on the side of
twitter on this one we've seen around
the world a number of governments who
are passing incredibly vague laws that
are designed solely with the purpose of
allowing them to restrict online content
well and above the way that they could
restrict content in an offline space or
in the regular media so we've seen an
alarming trend of legislation being
passed that allows countries to go back
to twitter and say look you're in
violation of ex-law you have to take
this content down which is completely um
legal and appropriate under
international freedom of expression
standards
melody pathway also in london it's an
alarming trend that governments are
doing the indian government threatened
twitter
employees with seven years in jail we've
seen twitter being forced to pay taxes
in nigeria and register locally there is
that an attack on the medium generally
or just on twitter
i think there's an attack on the medium
i mean you talked about uh nigeria
twitter was banned during nine months in
the country and when we talk about
threats physical threats actually uh
against twitter employees in india
google faced similar threats google
employees in russia just a couple of
months ago so we definitely are seeing
government's attempt at taking control
over the information that is being
circulating on the internet and taking
lots of different measures whether
they're legislations or other attempts
at um taking control at all costs for
glenn zarbazi uh the legal side of this
seems to be down to either the social
media giants policing themselves and
having a policy in place that allows
them uh to be the arbiters of what is
freedom of speech and what isn't or
governments individually cracking down
is that a tenable situation
yeah thank you for your question and
while i agree with the previous speakers
and indeed we're seeing both vague laws
by governments whose interest is more to
a rather constrained speech more so than
potentially legitimate illegal interest
of lawfulness or let's say content
against minors or etc other important
interests or the fact that if you look
at the data that twitter has published
specific individuals specific
journalists are sometimes targeted or
their accounts are requested to be shut
down at the same time the reason why
this is such a challenging issue of
content moderation and also it's overall
a question of how do we regulate these
kind of platforms and what we've seen as
someone with expertise both in u.s and
european law and seeing this from both
sides of the pond the challenge that we
continuously see is also the
disagreement around what is the primary
value that we want to safeguard is it
really a speech or limiting speech are
we safeguarding privacy for example a
concern that's been consistent in the
case of the european union
and oftentimes obviously a lot of the
governments cannot come to agreement
within themselves so for example in the
us too if we're taking privacy as a
matter there's so many discrepancies
between let's say what happens to in
california with what happens in other
states and and even so at the global
level and as we often say in when we
talk about from a legal side of things
that we can't really speak of one
internet where we speak of many internet
platforms because there's so many it's a
patchwork and it's a bits and pieces of
regulation that is making it difficult
what's increasingly also hard as some of
the traditional challenges that we're
seeing whether that's from the side of
lobbying in terms of the kind of
regulation that should be in place
whether that comes down from lack of
consistency and in administrations and
priorities and understanding the kind of
technology
that's at stake so in this sense we've
seen the european union taking trying to
take some bolder steps whether that was
in the case of
content moderation or privacy
protections but indeed as
coming to an overall one global model i
would say that's extremely unlikely
taken into account that so many of the
big countries actually have more of an
interest to leave things vague and under
their discretion more so than to come to
a more global agreement in terms of what
kind of rules can we agree across the
board what would be genuinely a content
regulation protecting legitimate
interests and what is actually purely an
attack on freedom of speech or media or
other protections that are legitimate in
a democratic society uh quinn mcew in
order to protect individuals rights in
order to protect the freedom of speech
one of the things that has been
discussed for a very long time is almost
a united nations charter of digital
human rights something that actually
codifies and suggests that this is
what's uh defendable and this is what is
protectable and given criminal elements
that is something that governments can
then deal with but our guest in
maastricht has said that's going to be
incredibly difficult to do do you think
it's going to be difficult to do and is
it a good idea frankly
so very interesting to see from the
reasons that we're just illuminate or
illustrated it will be incredibly
difficult to do i think one of the
things we also shouldn't lose sight of
is that under the universe of
declaration of human rights and the
international covenant on civil
political rights as well as some of
these more soft law declarations that
have come from the human rights council
on the internet there is a fairly robust
structure out there that protects these
rights and these structures do not
necessarily
discriminate between an offline right
and online right one of the things we've
consistently called for
as an organization is that the
recognition of the rights that are
available to people in an offline
standing whether it comes freedom of the
media freedom of speech right to privacy
be respected in the online context that
means there's some translation that
needs to happen in terms of moving it
right from one place to the other but we
wouldn't want to wholesale try and
create a new rights framework but
actually the rights frameworks that
already exist would provide a robust
protection for these rights
uh would you agree melody patrick that
there are already systems in place that
doesn't need to be codified centrally
yeah i would say that there are lots of
protections and lots of safeguards
establish international law that do
guarantee those rights where the
challenge comes is in the implementation
of
these these fundamental rights that
exist but also in holding companies
accountable because as much as
governments have to an obligation to
support and to enforce fundamental
rights
companies have somehow escaped um
have sometimes escaped scrutiny and
accountability when it comes to
to implementing some of the the
regulations or even just um
and enforcing some of some of our human
rights in in the digital world and it's
been really difficult to find a
comprehensive regulation worldwide
specifically applying to social media
companies for example but we know that a
lot more mechanisms are possible for
them to be more transparent for them to
really be accountable to be more
responsive so there are definitely
mechanisms that can be put in place um
besides uh what would be like a global
regulatory framework while some of these
global regulatory frameworks are
necessary we've seen the success uh in
europe for example of the data
protection gdpr and and we can think of
other
uh similar initiatives that have been
an advance for for human rights and for
the protection of our human rights
online uh vignenza often we've looked at
social media companies as conglomerates
as businesses as corporations which
means they've escaped the kind of
scrutiny that say public broadcasters
come under like for example you have
ofcom in the uk you have regulatory laws
in the us and in the uk that govern what
can go on air and what can be printed
etc because we view them as being
corporations now is it is there a need
to change the definition of what a
social media company is
yeah so that's a fantastic question and
actually links very well with what i was
going to also reply in sense of what
already was said let's say for the gdpr
so i would just like to take a moment to
go back to that point because while for
example that particular law was welcome
in the sense of its ambition to regulate
and to put the interest and the consent
of individuals and privacy at the
forefront it still fundamentally does
not challenge the business model under
which these corporations work and
actually as many scholars and myself
have argued that is at the heart of the
problem and this links with what you're
asking which is is it just a question of
design or is law in itself in a way has
its are its tools uh outdated to
actually deal with the kind of problems
that the current technologies the
current corporations are presenting and
that's precisely what we're seeing also
in the us and some to some extent in
europe as well when we have discussions
around using antitrust laws competition
rules to try to break down sort of if we
think of data as the new oil so to speak
or can we apply those older mechanisms
those traditional legal frameworks that
we have in order to manage it
differently
and this is actually where in a way the
regulators fail because they're
consistently sort of falling back to uh
potentially either non-innovative or not
bold enough reforms in order to truly
create a different playing field because
i fully agree with what was said in a
sense it's not about uh questions of
content moderation or specific rights or
do we have enough international
instruments at stake rather what's the
main problem is the lack of
understanding that we have right now
globally
such a mixture between public and
private power in the sense that we're
lacking the kind of innovativeness of
new accountability instruments and new
accountability thinking in order to
match the new realities in which we're
facing with and then following falling
back down to questions the first
amendment speech regulation or issues
around constitutional rights and privacy
etc those are very traditional
frameworks which are useful and of
course to be respected however i do
think right now
we need new efforts and in this regard i
think a lot of colleagues that i'm
seeing across the board are gathering
data there is a different kind of
momentum which is much more promising
that we're seeing in the sense of
understanding the nature of the bees
better in order to see actually how do
we really deal with regulation because
there's the lack of fuel regulation is
not good bad regulation is equally not
okay even if there's lack of compliance
because we simply then even further
discourage the kind of and so that has
been a little bit the challenge finding
that nuance finding that right tone with
which to regulate this
and considering that it's not a national
issue considering that we're truly
talking about as you said global
corporations which are based in one
country operate in another have their
data sets stored in another place
they're full form the internet and and
entire areas of countries let's say
myanmar that you mentioned before for a
lot of people facebook is synonymous the
equivalent to the internet in full so
there's a lot of also discrepancies
across the globe in the kind of the
playing field as i mentioned that we're
seeing with between regulators private
actors and what does that mean for
citizens and for the legitimate
interests and values that we want to
protect uh quinn mchugh is there a a
collusion between the governments and
social media companies that actually
stops any kind of real
regulation from coming into place after
all if they are corporations then they
get tax benefits they get freedom to do
whatever they want to do to make a
profit and they don't have to have the
same laws that say public broadcasters
uh do or other
media companies do so is there an
advantage for this vagueness for the
social media companies and for the
governments
i think one of the things that we all
need to remember as you pointed out is
that at the end of the day these are
profit-making entities who are private
corporations private or publicly traded
corporations who are driven by the
bottom line
and as much as they attempt to protect
freedom of expression or talk about
freedom of expression at the end of the
day they need to do what they need to do
from their own corporate perspective to
protect their company to protect their
own staff and to protect the profits
that they make um we just mentioned
about how a number of countries
the distinction between the internet and
facebook doesn't exist because the only
internet is the facebook internet that
people are given access to
that raises questions of as you pointed
out are they do they need to be treated
the same way that other corporations do
because
corporations have their their own
interests and some of the things that
we've seen in particular uh you
mentioned at the beginning of this uh
segment how india has threatened some of
twitter's staff with the rest for
non-compliance with certain indian
regulations or laws
we are increasingly seeing that
governments have absolutely no
compunction to to basically hold staff
hostage to require companies to hold
offices to hold staff in certain
locations we see that with russia with
their landing law um that came into
effect this year we've seen it in turkey
with some of the legislation they've
passed to try and require companies to
house and have offices there and those
are ways of trying to exert pressure
on on companies so it's it's a little
bit
hard to say that they're in collusion
with governments they're in a space
where they're trying to preserve their
own best interests and we should never
lose sight of that that as much as we
rely on them sometimes to help us
protect rights they also have their own
their own interests and their own
threats and that will not necessarily
always be in line with the protection of
human rights uh melody part three let's
just leave alone the corporation uh and
the idea of social media giants just for
a second this also comes down to
individuals as well i'll give you a
personal case uh whenever i've flown to
the us certainly in the last couple of
years um well actually before the
pandemic now actually i'm losing track
of time here um i've often been asked to
give my social media passwords
as an individual going through secondary
immigration
there's been no compunction to actually
give those over but the tone is if you
don't it's going to be very difficult
for you to enter so governments are
using this on an individual level is
that how alarming
is that for you
it is very concerning and if we put this
in the context of increased surveillance
online and also the targeting the
illegal targeting of journalists human
rights defenders
human rights lawyers across the world i
mean in the past few months there have
been a number of revelations about such
surveillance practice
so it is alarming indeed because we are
seeing that governments themselves have
their own agenda and that their own
agenda sometimes are not legitimate um
as much as yes this information is an
issue it has to be tackled because it is
a threat to our democracies likewise
incitement to violence online
sexist uh abused racist abuse and so on
like there are issues that need to be
addressed actually they need to be
addressed offline as well as online we
are also seeing um
a trend towards control towards
surveillance towards an erosion of our
civic space and towards an erosion of
our rights and of our democratic values
and some some of the some of the that
threat has come directly from some
governments and sometimes even from some
governments
that are not so-called authoritarian or
that can push forward some um
well-intentioned measures so this is
something that we cannot deny
as much as
we we are facing lots of different
challenges and we need to address and i
think in this community experts are
still
finding like discussing to find
solutions appropriate solutions to these
issues but we also must recognize that
attacks against the media attacks
against the press surveillance online
targeting of human rights defenders and
an attempt to
censor
the internet has has become a biggest
issue in the past few years vic lenza
but this is not just about the social
media giants it's not just about
governance here because often google
facebook um instagram all of their ceos
will turn around and say actually we are
trying to protect people's freedom of
speeches leave it to us we are best
placed to be able to do this but isn't
that a bit like putting the fox in
charge of the hen house
yeah so i actually argued exactly what
you're just saying in a sense in
particular for facebook because along
for the longest time it was
self-regulation is the best kind of
regulation and obviously even facebook
facebook's effort for example with its
so-called oversight board which tries to
be diverse and sort of have these very
in a way esteemed individuals who uh are
members of that board
the thing is that it i just want to
correct something in the sense that uh
there are some conflicting interests
that they have themselves uh so what
these corporations in the end they
depend on the trust of their users they
depend on their users liking their
products and and sort of being able to
um so in that sense if people
continuously feel attacked and safe or
if it ends up being something that they
don't want to use there's obviously
their disincentive on their side and not
an interest to actually have so there is
an interest on their in their side to
sort of say hey we rather have this
blamed on the regulator the fact that we
have to shut down your account rather
than say oh you have to hate us for
doing that or this is something that
we've decided in a way it also provides
a cover for them so to speak that you
can sort of
blame it or so to speak say that it's a
question of compliance rather than
saying it's a question of them deciding
something because in the end it gives
them that buffer that they can host a
variety of individuals some more freedom
of speech oriented others may be more
privacy oriented human rights activists
or whatnot the challenge overall here in
terms of the regulation who regulates
what and and how and how that should be
done is that there is a question
generally here of as i said also before
there is the stake of just the kind of
power that they have and in the end of
the day uh a corporation can no longer
just simply hide behind this corporate
veil and say we're only accountable to
our shareholders when they're actually
holding so much public power and so much
public influence globally whether it's
elections whether it's speech whether
it's protests
and so in that sense uh it's it's not
sufficient to sort of say that we're
able to initially to to limit our own
powers
but i have to say that there has been a
shift in that direction from a lot of
companies and what's disappointing
i'm really sorry we are running out of
time but there is a question i want to
ask all three of you just very quickly
i'll begin with uh quinn mchugh i've had
a social media account for over i think
12 13 years now why is legislation taken
so long
or even the thought and the talk of
legislation
it's an interesting question i think
the
initially early on the global approach
to these companies i think had was led
by
um some of the way they were treated in
the united states which is basically
hands off we want this new technology
this new way of communicating to
flourish we want to treat these
companies as just merely intermediaries
um for the free flow of information and
therefore we want to protect them as
neutral intermediaries right from
adverse actions because of the content
which would be on them which is
inherently speech restricting or rights
violating to punish the intermediary for
the the content that's hosted sorry we
are running out of time i do want to
come to the other guests as well vig
lenses just very quickly just uh very
quickly what are your thoughts
my quick tweet if i may say so to your
question would be that uh it's actually
not true that we're just talking about
it now but i think we're just talking
with the level of alarm and urgency and
widespread globally more so because i
think many of us have actually expressed
concerns but of course i agree with the
previous speaker that we've also
expressed an excitement but i think it's
a fantastic opportune moment to have
more public awareness and to hopefully
have better tools going forward both
from the legislators and public pressure
to end up having better rules than what
we've had now uh melody do you have 140
characters you want to share with us
of course and as you mentioned earlier
in the conversation the the the coveted
pandemic has affected it has pushed even
more people online at a time when we
were also seeing some people deprived
from internet connections because of
internet shutdowns or other issues and
so we it's true that it is not a new
issue but there is definitely a lot more
attention to the issue and i think that
a lot of uh legislators are also under
pressure because we we we deserve more
to be honest like we we deserve more
from our legislators and we also deserve
more from the companies and and and the
platform that we use to exercise our
rights i want to thank all our guests
quinn mchugh viglenza abbasi and melody
party and i want to thank you two for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story and you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me imran khan and
the whole team here bye for now
you